to the point of the small influencers
when I launched my book and it's still
something we're doing now what we do is
we go to Amazon look at what similar
books they recommend to mine so it's
like for work week and tools of titans
and you know all the other
entrepreneurship related bugs then we go
to youtube and look at who's done a
review of these books and then we reach
out to each of them individually and say
hey evan has this book it's about this
we saw you wrote about for work week
would you like to do a review of this
book and most people just do it for free
I offered it oh do they do it because of
you and you have a big channel and they
want to hope there's maybe some
reciprocity in the future I mean could
the average Joe or Jill do what you did
it definitely helps like we pick you two
because I'm known on YouTube in in a
niche right like I'm known for
entrepreneurs in YouTube I'm not like
known by everywhere on YouTube but I'm
doing it there instead of snapchat or
somewhere else because I'm known in that
community so absolutely I can do that in
a way that others might have a harder
time doing it but if you're an expert on
leadership like they may resonate with
some of your messages you can still like
your hit rate won't be as high but it's
still a viable strategy to go with and
and some of them like we'll do a shout
out to some people on some videos say
hey Thank You Jill for profile my book
go check out your channel that kind of
stuff and I also involve offered to be
involved on some of the videos like if
you want something from Evan you want an
intro you want to ask him a question you
want something I'll make a pre-recorded
video that they can use in their videos
as well and so the bulk of our effort I
have my assistant spend a lot of time
basically every week she goes and does
that and looks at what are the books
that are related to mine which youtubers
I covered those books and then shall we
count to them and we have a constant
stream of channels of different sizes
under a thousand subs for a lot of them
to creating content and then I'll tweet
out the video and I'll help promote it
and like they get some exposure and
there may be some name recognition with
me and they may not have an idea who I
am but it's been effective in getting
the message out and it's something that
we consistently do I'm wondering if
everyone picked up on something
I did that Evan just said and that is he
just went around and he knocked on a
bunch of youtuber doors and asked them
to help him promote his book I I don't I
can count on one hand and we've worked
with hundreds of brands how many of
those how many the brands we worked with
have very even thought about doing that
or have done that they don't have to go
and pay us to do that they could do it
themselves now maybe they don't know how
it's not that hard to figure out you
don't have to hire us to do something
like that but at a minimum I'm thinking
if you got a new product at you're an
entrepreneur what a great way to get the
message out about your product or
service even if you don't have a huge
channel like like Evan does yeah for
some people it's an honor like for some
people I was the first person ever reach
out to them and offer something and then
to be involved to have me involved in a
video and say something and to have a
shout-out on my channel you know doesn't
take a lot the exchange could be will
tweet your video from our account that
when it comes out or put it on our blog
or so right yeah I mean and if your
brand is value in that and they can say
we just worked with Heinz or BMW or
whatever
even though was zero costs like you can
leverage just like I'm leveraging my
name in the YouTube entrepreneur unity
my brand is associated with it you could
do the same thing people are now some of
those people are saying i collab with
Evan Carmichael and that makes them look
better for the next things they do so
the brand you can use that to your
benefit to help help them get more deals
and you don't have to pay anything